esto es cohetes katiushka que cayeron
esta mañana en bagdad uno de ellos muy
cerca al hotel babylon el hotel más
importante de la ciudad donde siempre
hay funcionarios del gobierno o
diplomáticos tienen la característica de
haber atacado zonas residenciales y
aunque obtuvo la fortuna no tener
víctimas humanas y se une a otro ataque
sucedido la semana pasada en el que
murieron cinco civiles entre ellos niños
esta es la primera vez que la sociedad
civil quedaba atrapada en este conflicto
que se viene dando desde hace muchísimos
meses en el que diferentes agrupaciones
atacan especialmente la llamada zona
verde de bagdad donde están las misiones
diplomáticas especialmente la embajada
estadounidense esto llevó a que la
semana pasada el secretario de estado
norteamericano mike pompeo pidiera al
gobierno iraquí protección o de lo
contrario amenaza con cerrar la embajada
en bagdad y retirar tres mil tropas en
el país lo mismo pidieron los demás
integrantes de las misiones diplomáticas
en bagdad que ven como su seguridad está
amenazada pero quiénes son los
responsables hoy el ejército asegura que
estos ataques son responsabilidad de
grupos
aristas o bandas armadas pero en el
pasado especialmente eeuu ha señalado a
milicias pro iraníes las cajillas
relacionadas con el ala más radical de
estar detrás de esos ataques